les visages sont fermés et l'ambiance
est pesante
une trentaine de députés maliens dont
l'élection est contestée au rouge est
l'un des points clés du plan de la
cedeao pour sortir de l'impasse
politique et économique dans laquelle se
trouve le pays
pour eux le message est clair ils ont
été élus et leur démission n'est pas au
goût du jour
la cedeao a failli ce n'est pas dans son
rôle les demandes ss et on peut avoir
d'autres solutions que d'aller vers la
division 2 un certain nombre de députés
j'ai démissionné points c'est moi j'ai
été élu dans ma commune et c'est la cour
constitutionnelle qui a fait son travail
je pense que les résultats sont là les
voix sont là mais quelqu'un qui conteste
il peut aller voir les montrer à
l'opinion publique nationale et
internationale que nous n'avons pas été
contestée et que nous ne sont pas
contestés et malgré tout aussi la cedao
maintien
sa proposition alors nous nous n'allons
jamais accepter accepté vraiment cette
proposition que nous trouvons injuste
cette demande des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest était censé estomper le climat
de tension due à l'invalidation fin
avril par la cour constitutionnelle
d'une trentaine de résultats des
élections législatives de mars avril
dont une dizaine en faveur du président
ibrahim boubacar kéïta le chef d'état
malien fait face un vaste mouvement de
contestation à bamako l'opposition
déterminée avoir démissionné ib cas et
demande désormais aux 6,7 du premier
ministre pour permettre la formation
d'un nouveau gouvernement
des mises en elles sont venues à bout
lui ai dit que la terre qui a été le
mouvement m5 appelle donc à une nouvelle
phase de la désobéissance civile au
cours des prochains jours une
protestation sans violence avec toujours
pour objectif la démission du président
malien